$1,000 per million views you've seen
everyone talking about the Tik Tok
creativity program making life-changing
amounts of cash but you haven't taken a
stab at it yet well in this video I'll
be fully breaking down how you can get
started today making Clips bringing in
thousands of dollars a month that's
simple well sort of let's get into it
real quick I'll go over the few
requirements to actually qualify for
this program but don't get your penties
in a WT there's ways around all of them
so make sure you're paying close
attention first your account needs to be
created in either us UK France Brazil
Germany Japan or Korea if you're not in
one of those countries I have a method
to get around this that I can't say on
YouTube but there's a free video at the
top of the description explaining it
like I said don't get your panties in a
l there's ways around it next 10,000
followers don't worry with the steps I'm
going to show you in this video it's
easy to hit that 10K follow Mark in as
little as 5 days lastly the only videos
that qualify for the program are 1
minute or longer videos that's why
you've seen so many videos on your feet
being 1 minute and 1 second long because
people are making bank off for this it's
time for step one pick a niche when
picking a niche for the Tik Tok
creativity program our goal is to get as
many views as possible you don't want to
pick a niche that has a narrow audience
we want something that millions of
people can enjoy I'm sure you've seen a
lot of guys on your feed talking about
clipping up your favorite streamers
maybe adding video game footage or
something and then throwing it on Tik
Tok to make money on the creativity
program that's actually a bad move
because there's a requirement with the
Tik Tok creativity program where the
content needs to be original so when
you're strictly clipping up other
people's videos your videos are now at
risk of getting demonetized so the best
move is to create a faceless Tik Tok
account utilizing AI there's a bunch of
niches you can go into doing this
history facts funny jokes creepy facts
animal facts current events cool facts
literally a million different routes my
best recommendation is finding something
that interests you and you wouldn't be
bored bored or annoyed to make videos of
every day some other methods that you
can do when finding a niche is as you
scroll on your feed and you see videos
over 1 minute long you can bookmark them
all into a folder that way you have a
bunch of ideas to come back to for
starting a new account another thing you
can do is just sit down with the
notebook for 10 minutes set a timer get
a pen and paper and write down as many
things that interest you as possible so
then once the 10 minutes is up you can
go to those individual topics look them
up on Tik Tok so then you can look
through all the top accounts you can go
through the hashtag analyze what other
people are doing well in that Niche that
interests you that way you have
inspiration right off the bat of what's
working for other people to start your
account now that you have your Niche
that leads us into step two your
FasTrack to 10K followers plan we're
here to generate millions of views and
get rich not reinvent the wheel adding
on to that last point of step one you
want to analyze the other best accounts
in your Niche so when you're looking at
those top accounts when you search up a
topic so let's say when you did that
journaling in your notebook you came up
with sports now what you can do is you
can go and you can search sports look at
all the top accounts look at all the top
hashtags and as you're doing this you're
going to write down the best accounts
all inside of a Google doc until you
have like at least 5 to 10 of them
basically what you're doing is just a
bunch of market research on what's doing
well in the niche you want to get into
once you have this done your whole list
of the accounts now you're going to go
through the accounts and look at their
best performing videos and then also
copy and paste those into a the point of
this is you're using these best
performing videos on the accounts of the
nich you're interested in for
inspiration on your first videos so you
can go viral as quickly as possible and
hit the 10K follower Mark just a real
quick point that a lot of you guys get
mixed up when I say something like this
is you're not just copying the video
fully but what you're doing is you're
taking inspiration from the hook topic
of the video and the call to action that
they use okay now you have your Niche
picked you have the best accounts and
the best performing videos of those
accounts that that you're going to use
for inspiration on your first few videos
to go viral as quick as possible the
fast track plan to 10K is done step
three create your video I'm going to
give a summarized explanation of the
video creation process here I have a
fully in-depth tutorial in my bio that I
can't post on YouTube so you can check
that out after the video too there's a
bunch of video niches that you can dive
into as I mentioned earlier but for the
sake of this video not being 4 hours
long I'll use the AI videos as an
example for your video creation process
as it actually covers most of the niches
step 3A make your script you're going to
create your script on chat gbt here's a
few prompts you can use so it gives you
the best script possible but basically
you want to be as descriptive as
possible let chat GPT know what other
video topics have done well and it'll
spit out a gray script now for the hook
I actually always recommend that you
make this custom that way you can grab
the viewers attention in the best way
possible because you need ideally 70% of
people watching until 3 seconds into the
video I could talk about making an
amazing hook for 3 hours but the main
principles are it's either a captivating
statement question or something
controversial that makes the viewer stop
scrolling then for the actual visual
aspect of it you want it to be extremely
extremely engaging so an initial zoom on
that first AI image that you have and
then Quick Cuts for the first 5 Seconds
of the video so there should be a new
image popping up basically every single
second and for the actual image itself
you want it to be as clear as possible
of what's going on in the video the main
thing is you want to think if I'm an NPC
scrolling on Tik Tok would I stop and
watch this video popping up on my feed
or would I keep scrolling if the answer
is you would keep scrolling ask yourself
why and then change that aspect of the
video maybe it's the hook script isn't
strong enough maybe it's hard to tell
what's going on with the visual and you
need to make a better picture analyze
your video from the third person I do
this on every single video I post fix it
up and you'll be good to go once your
chat gbt made script and custom hook are
done you want to turn the script you
just made into an AI voice to do that
you're going to head over to 11 Labs
copy and paste the script use one of the
voices it provides you or you can even
make a custom voice of a celebrity or
something you can get creative with it
one major trick you guys see me talking
about a lot is called tricking the
droids where the aspect is you're
putting something onto your video that
gets people to comment rewatch or
continue watching the video at the start
of my mom reacts videos I had a DVD logo
bouncing behind me that's a big reason
why people add video game footage to the
bottom of their Tik toks for something
like this you can put like a Morgan
Freeman voice on you talking about
celebrities cuz that might get people to
comment and rewatch you can put a James
charl Voice or you can intentionally
make the voice sound a little bit zesty
I've done that on some of the accounts
that I'm running that's gotten a lot of
people to rewatch tons of different
routes you can go for this get creative
with it script and voice over done now
you need to make the images that will go
along the video to do this head over to
Mid Journey give an in-depth prompt
illustrating what's going on in the
script and would fit the video and it
will generate high quality images to use
ideally you have a new image popping up
around every 1.5 seconds of the video
that way there's more stimulation on the
screen and you're always grabbing the
viewers attention you then want to add
stuff like zooms key frames and effects
to the screen so it's always moving and
even more eye grabbing to the viewer and
they're just sucked in like an NPC that
way it doesn't just look like a
slideshow this is especially more
prevalent in the hook like I mentioned
earlier where you want every
8 to 1 second the image shifting with an
effect on it that way people are sucked
in as much as possible now that the
video is basically done it's getting a
bit easier now it's time to add captions
for this I recommend using cap cut if
you're new to editing and you only have
a smart device what am I Boomer
calling this smart device whatever but
if you have Adobe or you're good at
Final Cut Pro or something that's
totally fine to use as well whatever
software you're going to use the autoc
captions feature and make them engaging
popping up one to three words at a time
a big mistake people make is they'll put
like two sets of lines or a whole
paragraph of captions that is not what
you want to do because then people are
going like this reading it all and
they're more likely to click off if you
have words constantly popping at
people's face it makes them more likely
to continue watching until the end of
the video that's why you see basically
every single short doing this nowadays
because everyone's picked up on it after
you add the autoc captions features in
just go back fix up any errors the auto
caption feature might have had and
that's your video real quick to one of
my favorite fonts that I use is bangers
just in case you guys are curious but
you can also look at the different fonts
that the software provides you and pick
whatever you like the main thing is
you're thinking if I was a viewer
watching this video would I want to keep
watching so like if you're posting more
scarier videos you can pick a scarier
font that'll match it more and might get
your retention on the video higher if
you're just posting regular videos on a
more normal topic you can use the
bangers font or one of your liking that
like I mentioned before there's multiple
ways to go about this with the different
niches and whatnot if you're doing doing
Reddit story times you might just need
the voiceover and then find a really
good Minecraft jumping clip and maybe
some popups if you're doing animal
related videos you can find stock
footage online instead of just using mid
Journey AI generated images there's also
a software where you can make a custom
image now speak to the camera utilizing
AI so then you could mix that AI
generated talking person in with the
other AI gener images stock photos you
can get creative with it you can mix all
this stuff together but like I said
there's a bunch of different paths that
you can do now that your video is
completely done congratulations it's
time for posting for this you want to
add a trending audio without lyrics that
complement the vibe of your video a big
mistake I see a lot of you guys do when
adding audios onto your Tik toks is
you'll just pick your favorite song at
the time or like an old Eminem song or
some like that and it'll sound
horrible because it's like rapping or
lyrics matching on with the video that
has talking in it so you don't want to
do that you want to find a trending
audio that complement the vibe if you
need to find a better audio you can like
go to your Niche and look at what other
accounts are using go to the trending
Tab and scroll down from the top bunch
of different routes you can do for a
whole list of the best sounds you can
find it at FG gr. comom as well we give
you all the tools you need and those
example accounts I mentioned earlier
that way you can save time and we give
you the best market research possible
but from here posting your first video
it's just rinse and repeat of this
process we went over watch the numbers
grow and cash roll in I didn't want to
make this video 25 hours long so I'm
hosting an extra live free explanation
diving into this even more we're only
allowed 500 slots on the software so if
you're interested make sure to go check
out that link at the top of the
description to see if there's any spots
left it's totally free so unless you
have a jerking off appointment or
something there's no reason that you
shouldn't be there learning this whole
video in much more depth but
congratulations you now know how to
properly attach the Tik to creativity
program make edit the videos so you can
find success in no time see you in that
webinar and in future videos later
guys